[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
let's bring in carson palmer the former
nfl quarterback of course heisman trophy
winner usc
uh
can you explain the kansas city chiefs
like what what what is the philosophy do
you think they have going into these
games including what happened against
the chargers
well when you look at the just the sheer
size of that defense that's how they're
built they are built to be in a
shootout week in and week out i mean
just look at tyron matthew who's one of
the better safeties in the league he's
all
175 pounds dripping wet you look at that
linebacker core they are built for speed
now you got chris jones and some pass
rushers up front but they have designed
and built that defense to run around and
defend the past they're not going to get
many games where they have to stop the
run where the opposing offense is going
to carry the ball 40 times a game
because they're assuming their offense
is going to be up some points
you could have tyrekil or travis kelsey
as a quarterback who do you want
i'd take kelsey just because at the end
of the day what's most important is
moving the chains and anytime they get
in third down
kelsey's an automatic chain mover
i i brought this up a couple of times
i'm watching last night with rogers
against the niners there's 37 seconds
left and i didn't know if that was
enough time because i thought okay san
francisco's either gonna put pressure on
rogers or they're gonna make sure
devonte adams doesn't beat them
they didn't either how is that possible
carson
aaron's that good i mean as much as much
heat as he takes and the drama that
comes and surrounds him it seems every
off season
he is that good i mean the ball he threw
late over the middle to devonte where he
just had enough touch on it over the
outstretched fingers of the defender's
hand i mean that ball is is one of one
there aren't many other quarterbacks if
any quarterbacks in the league that can
make that pass
okay but you know devonte adams is his
go-to guy
what what kind of defense
was san francisco trying to play there
well they were in zone and earlier in
the game you saw him in man and anytime
they get man and devonte's on the
outside they throw the ball over the top
they throw the ball to his back shoulder
i mean he caught three or four back
shoulder balls in that game but they
also threw three or four long incomplete
go balls over the top that they didn't
complete so as a corner you just don't
know what to do you don't know if it's
coming quick on your back shoulder you
don't know if he's airing it out
throwing it down the field and they do
just enough of both to where as a
defender you have to be ready for that
long ball and you got to try to react
that back shoulder throw yeah but how
about i double cover devonte adams
right anybody else can beat me
if they do congratulations i can't let
your best player beat me
yeah but devonta is so smart devonte is
in the slot devonte is in short motions
he's a the single receiver on a three by
one formation i mean he's so good in in
that system and knows that system so
well that lefleur does a great job of
moving him around where you can't always
double a guy now if a guy's playing only
backside or weak side receiver you can
double him because you know where he's
going to be you don't know where devonte
is going
do you know rogers at all
yes
how how what what can you tell us like
how would you describe him
um as just a guy as a dude
yeah well no i mean you're watching him
as as a quarterback to a quarterback
like what what is it that makes him so
special and then i want to ask you about
him off the field
oh i think he's he's the worst thing for
a young quarterback like mac jones or
some of these guys that come into the
league because you can't watch him he
will kill your confidence you will watch
him on film
and see him do things and go man i know
i can't do that do i have to be able to
do that and throw that ball to be
successful in this league so the first
thing i do with these young quarterbacks
is say watch watch as much film as you
can do not watch any green bay film
[Laughter]
that's awesome
i've never heard that analysis because
everybody wants to try to replicate you
know the best and you would just say
look
remove that guy
and then you can try to
try to emulate some of these other guys
watch as much film as you can there's
you shouldn't be watching espn or the
dan patrick show you should be watching
film and film and film just don't ever
watch green bay film especially from a
fundamental and technique standpoint i
mean he does so many things your coach
not to do as a young kid as far as
you know stepping into throws being on
balance staying on platform he throws so
many balls off his back foot that he
just flicks
and and it's just it's a confidence
killer for a young quarterback
what's he like off the field
he's awesome i love him i i play golf
with him a bunch i've been around him a
bunch um he's very guarded he needs to
be very guarded he's one of the most
polarizing figures and probably all of
sports but
um to to people that that call in
friends everybody loves him
yeah i always tell people that you know
i played golf with him a couple of times
and have been around him and i've i've
felt the sense of humor that he has like
you know he can jab you and you know
it's it's like a boxer he'll kind of hit
and then he'll back up a little bit you
know and
but he's not for everybody would you say
that that's
true yeah i mean like i said he's
extremely guarded so if you're if you're
on the outside you're on the outside but
he's funny he's quick-witted he's got
way more interest than just football or
sports he's into a lot of different
things but like i said i mean for so the
guys that know him and guys that have
been close and spent time with him i
don't know anybody that doesn't love him
he's carson palmer joining us on the
program former nfl quarterback heisman
trophy winner at usc i was wondering
about sean mcvay's role now with matthew
stafford and how that's different for a
head coach
during a game with stafford as opposed
to jared goff
i i really don't think it's that that
you know that far off um you know
they've come out and been so explosive
and and really just pretty i mean
everything they do it's pretty to watch
but play calling though carson does it
it felt like he was always in jared
goff's ear or we were given that
impression
i don't think so i think you saw that
early with jared goff because those were
really jared goff's first couple years
in the league matt's got a lot more
years you know i i think matt moves a
little better than jared but they're
really similar you know style
quarterbacks i thought you know jared
got a bad rap but i thought jared could
flat out spin it i mean he really threw
the ball well stafford throws a little
bit better
stafford has way more experience he's
been in a lot of you know a lot more
seasons a lot more games but at the end
of the day stafford's older you know i
think goff's got a longer runway he's
gonna probably play three four five more
years after stafford retires
and that was a lot to give up for a very
similar style skill set player but i
think you're seeing it with matt i mean
matt moves a little bit better he's a
little bit quicker he does a better job
getting outside the pocket than jared
did but but still i mean i you know like
i said i thought jared got a bad rap and
took a lot of heat for what went down in
la but i think jerry can flat throw it
would you rather face miles garrett or
aaron donald
[Music]
i would rather face miles garrett
because at least you can step up in the
pocket when he wins on the outside rush
but i played against aaron twice a year
for a long time when i was in arizona
and he wreaks havoc inside the pocket
and i i thought that was kind of a you
know that that's the thing that you've
seen brady struggle with i was i was
thinking the rams were going to end up
winning yesterday because when brady's
had a difficult time you know back to
the super bowls against the giants
and some of the the situations he's been
in where when he doesn't have a pocket
to step up into he's not going to beat
you with his legs everybody knows that
but when he can't step up and accurately
deliver the ball because he's stepping
into throws and transferring his weight
into throws
he's going to have a tough time beating
you like he did yesterday against the
rams yeah i agree with you that aaron
donald is so valuable
just from that perspective of they line
him up at different places but that
pressure up the middle
there aren't many guys who can do it
they can give you pressure but they
can't get to the quarterback like hello
di nada and some of those guys
like they put pressure but they're not
necessarily getting to you aaron donald
is a unicorn
did you face anybody who was similar to
aaron donald
aside from aaron no but i my first i
think it was one of our first games in
arizona back when the rams were in st
louis
we we were
i think it was a division clinching game
in st louis it was really odd the
stadium was quiet there was nobody there
there was really bad lighting in that
stadium and i got back to the huddle and
one of my good buddies lyle's in line
was the center and aaron had just come
on the scene he was just drafted and i
think we're up a couple scores it's the
end of the fourth fourth quarter we had
heard of this this aaron donald guy but
he wasn't a top two or three pick
you know so there wasn't a lot of film
on him there wasn't a lot of talk about
him but i got back in the huddle i
started calling play and lyle looked up
to me and said don't call it don't call
it i'm like why he goes i can't even see
the guy let alone block him like who are
you talking about 99 99 don't call that
inside zone play i can't block it and
that was my first like you know aaron's
welcome to the mo you know welcome to
the nfl moment because then i went back
and watched the film and we didn't
hardly block him at all and and you know
nothing's changed since that's you know
game six seven eight years ago okay so
how do you react when your center says
don't call that i can't block the guy
i called an outside screen
i changed the play
did donald get you that game
he got me plenty times that game
he's a pro i mean he is an absolute
problem and now
that was back before everybody knew you
know how good he was that was back when
he was getting a lot of one-on-one
single blocks
now
entire game plans are built around him
so he's hardly one-on-one with anybody
can you hear an outside rusher
going by you
or do you just no
no yes something you just sensed i mean
it's kind of a sixth sense thing you've
been in that moment so many times and
practiced that moment so many times you
know it's so loud in there and then you
know you've probably got a coach still
you know yelling something in your ear
and all that's going on around you you
just gotta feel it and sense it
who's the best outside guy you faced
um
man when i was young and came in the
league strahan was strahan was a problem
i mean he was so big he was so physical
and long and that's the thing about
strahan too is he would bull rush you
from the outside and he had justin tuck
and some other guys inside of him so he
was one on one and he wouldn't
necessarily beat you with speed around
the pocket but he would collapse the
tackle into your lap so kind of like
aaron donald he would make
he would shrink the size of the pocket
just with a bulrush on the outside edge
what do you see when you see justin
herbert
you know i i watched the the ram game or
the charger game and i also watched um
who was the other game right before him
oh it was it was the justin fields game
in chicago
and the two differences i noticed and
aside from justin herbert being a
physical specimen i mean he is just
bigger quicker and has an absolute hose
but
the way they protect him with the play
calling was so different than what was
going on in chicago you very rarely saw
justin herbert with the chargers drop
back in a seven step drop everything was
off the run if they were taking a long
deep drop they were doing six and seven
man protections off of play action and
then they got the ball out really really
quick when they were spreading people
out the ball wasn't in his hands past a
three-step drop before you knew it he
had the ball and shotgun boom balls out
then you go and watch you go and watch
justin fields in that chicago game and
then you do anything to protect him
so you know when i'm watching
justin herbert play i'm seeing a really
really good job and he's not even that
young anymore i mean justin fields is
young justin fields is in game one
herbert's in year two and they're still
doing a really good job in la protecting
him
lots of long play action they're running
the ball effectively they're throwing
screens and then they're getting in the
quick game and getting the ball out of
his hands so i really like the way
they're moving the pocket and adjusting
the game plan to protect justin herbert
and vice versa i don't like what they're
doing in chicago with with justin fields
i mean you know when he's dropping back
by formation alone so you're seeing
defensive line pin their ears back and
come after him okay but carson you're
saying this you're not even there
it feels like how does matt nagging it
felt like it was irresponsible what the
bears did to justin fields
yeah at the same time though i will say
justin fields and chicago bears don't
have anybody that can win one-on-one
outside
and so
if you put ma if you put andy dalton in
that same situation you don't have the
ability for andy dalton to make
something out of nothing like justin
fields can so
they're in a tough spot in chicago
because they just don't have any winners
on the outside they don't have a true
number one receiver that can just flat
out win for you so they got to get
creative and then they also have to
account for the quarterback making
something out of nothing three four five
third downs a game where they can do it
with their legs and andy dalt doesn't
have that ability but justin fields
gives them that ability are you all in
on the raiders
i like them i i'll tell you what i like
i like two things i'm not all in on the
raiders until they get to week 15 16 17.
um i'll tell you what i like though i
really like that defensive front that
defensive front is stout that defensive
front can get after the passer a little
bit
they don't have a true pass rusher they
got rid of khalil mack obviously but
they got a lot of guys they platoon in a
lot of stout salty defensive lineman so
they can stop the pat they can stop the
run they can get after the passer but
the other thing i really like about them
is derek carr is playing with a true
toughness and a true grit that i really
hadn't seen and i don't think
i don't think gruden had seen it before
but
you watched these last two three weeks
of watching him play he's stepping into
throws taking one in the face he's
moving around the pocket late he's not
giving up and throwing the ball away
he's not getting in uh two minute
situations and throwing the quick drag
to get the ball out of bounds all the
time he's holding the ball in the pocket
he's taking hits and he's delivering it
accurately down the field and i hadn't
seen that uh out of derek carr yet so
i'm really i'm really surprised and
proud of the way he stepped in the
pocket and played with a lot of grit you
still have your raiders jersey
uh i do not i do not have a raiders
jersey my kids do though my kids still
wear a number three raiders jersey yeah
but you don't have your
raiders
do you have any memorabilia up in your
house
uh
no i've got pictures of my kids
i've got kids toys
yeah i know no no jerseys no jerseys up
no jerseys
no jerseys damn
so disappointing
um
no it's just surprising i guess i didn't
know if you had a a a room and you know
like you're how your kids are old enough
to know that dad played in the nfl but
you don't you don't take a trip you
don't strike me as taking a trip down
memory lane
we don't we don't take a lot of trips
down memory lane but let me ask you guys
how many bobble heads do you have of
yourself in your office right there a
few of them
okay yeah yeah
yeah
i i love me carson i mean i love taking
a trip down memory lane let me tell you
about the days at sportscenter you know
like yeah
so well if you have any jerseys that you
don't want up but you want me to put
them up in the man cave then i'll be
more than happy to i got barry sanders
there dan marino there farve there
tom brady there reggie miller
adam sandler from the longest yard
so there's all this run around and and
that all you had to do was ask me for
jersey you don't have to go around
the room my back is like my bad just ask
well just
uh
if you got a jersey and you want to
donate to the man cave
we'd love to send you a jersey that'd be
great all right tell fred it's uh it's
coming up
you know what i'll get the fedex number
and send it to you
there you go all right thank you hey
great to talk to you buddy
thanks darren that's carson palmer i
love that analysis where you're saying
to these rookie quarterbacks hey
whatever you do do not watch aaron
rodgers